uno de los episodios de fenómenos
climatológicos más violentos en la
historia de kentucky múltiples tornados
golpearon el estado dejando decenas de
fallecidos y numerosos daños en
viviendas
cuando nos estamos acercando al final
del tornado más severo en la historia de
kentucky múltiples tornados han tocado
tierra y tenemos daños en más de una
docena de condados el quinto quien a
bolívar ahora ya son contra quienes han
sido varias las ciudades afectadas pero
fue la localidad de mayfield la que se
llevó la peor parte donde un tornado
termo una fábrica en la que estaban
trabajando más de 100 personas
provocando una cifra masiva de víctimas
más al norte en el estado de illinois
muchas personas quedaron atrapadas tras
el derrumbe del techo de uno de los
almacenes de amazon algo que ha
impactado a los vecinos de la zona están
a salvo eso es todo lo que importa
quiero decir las ramas de los árboles
cayeron sobre el sótano por lo demás ya
sabe tienen a su hija ya abajo su perro
mientras las autoridades y los equipos
de rescate siguen con su operativo se
espera que el episodio de tornados
llegue a su fin en los últimos años eeuu
se ha visto golpeado por diversos
fenómenos meteorológicos extremos
desde fuertes lluvias hasta sequías y
olas de calor o algo que los expertos
achacan en gran parte al cambio
climático